The price of pork, China's favorite meat, rose sharply this year...
...that's forced many to cut back.
But this shopper jokes she'll never give it up.
If people don't eat pork then their faces turn green, the color of vegetables.
You have to eat meat.
No meat, no strength.
But meat was a luxury in China just a few decades ago.
Food was strictly rationed until the 1980s.
Chinese ate meat only once or twice a month...
...when Chinese Academy of Social Sciences Economist...
...Zhu Ling was growing up.
Only during Chinese New Year could we get 250 grams of pork each.
And I recall I could only get 750 grams of cooking oil per year.
Deng Xiaoping's economic reforms in the 1980s...
...set the stage for China's miraculous growth.
"And as happens everywhere, when people emerge from poverty,..."
"...the Chinese began to eat better," Zhu says.
This was an era of change and improvement in food consumption.
Basically, apart from vegans, everybody, every family...
...has seen an increase in meat and seafood consumption.
Chinese pork consumption has more than doubled since 1990...
...and chicken consumption is up fivefold.
Livestock need to eat, too.
So, feeding those rapidly growing herds and flocks...
...has quickly made China the world's most voracious consumer of soybeans.
According to US Department of Agriculture Analyst Hui Jiang,...
..."Ten to 15 years ago, China imported almost virtually no soybeans at all."
And so, since the mid-1990s Chinese imports have grown drastically...
...to today, dominating over half of the total world trade in soybeans.
This has been positive for American agriculture.